hola a todos bienvenidos a este tutorial
sobre cómo comenzar el aprendizaje a
distancia con khan academy kids que es
khan academy kids es una aplicación
divertida y educativa para niños de 2 a
7 años es gratuita y tiene cientos de
actividades y libros en inglés
por qué usar khan academy kits en el
aprendizaje a distancia es fácil de usar
se configura rápidamente y puede usarse
sin conexión está enfocada en los niños
desarrolla sus habilidades de lectura
escritura y matemáticas así como
habilidades socioemocionales al tiempo
que estimula su creatividad es alegre y
educativa nuestros cinco personajes o
los sandy real ipec y cody ver el
narrador guían a los niños a través de
juegos interactivos e historias fue
creada en colaboración con expertos en
aprendizaje de stanford y está alineada
con la head start early learning
outcomes framework y los common core
standards
es 100% gratuita nunca verás publicidad
en ella ni necesitarás una suscripción
ahora vamos a mostrarte los aspectos
básicos de cómo comenzar y cómo aprender
en casa con tus hijos en khan academy
kids khan academy kids es una aplicación
móvil distinta a la aplicación de khan
academy oa la experiencia de khan
academy en la computadora está
disponible para tu teléfono inteligente
ya sea ios de apple o android así como
en chromebooks de pantalla táctil y
puedes encontrarla en la tienda de
aplicaciones que utilizas
una vez descargada la aplicación en tu
dispositivo ábrela para comenzar después
de la bienvenida de nuestros personajes
te llevará a la página de registro haz
clic en sign of te va a pedir la
dirección de correo eléctronico de un
adulto ingresa a la tuya selecciona en
next
recibirás un correo de welcome back and
academic it's punto org para verificar
la creación de tu cuenta
en el mensaje haz clic en el botón azul
de verificación para activarla
ahora puedes regresar a la aplicación
para crear el perfil de usuario de tu
hijo ingresa su nombre y su edad y elige
un avatar si tienes más de un hijo
puedes crear un perfil de usuario para
cada uno
al presionar el perfil de tu hijo te
llevará a la página de inicio aquí vas a
encontrar diferentes maneras de aprender
puedes elegir el botón verde en la casa
para comenzar una aventura de
aprendizaje personalizada otra opción es
seleccionar el icono del libro en la
esquina superior izquierda para ir a la
biblioteca donde podrás elegir
actividades para practicar habilidades
también puedes presionar algunos de los
personajes en la parte inferior de la
página de inicio para explorar el kitsch
club
bien pero entonces cuál es la diferencia
entre la ruta de aprendizaje
personalizada y la biblioteca la ruta de
aprendizaje personalizada es una
reproducción automática de todas
nuestras actividades matemáticas lectura
aprendizaje socio-emocional libros y
vídeos está adecuada por edad para
ajustarse al nivel en el que se
encuentra tu hijo
la ruta de aprendizaje puede ser una
buena idea si no puedes estar ahí para
elegir cada actividad que tu hijo va a
realizar durante cierto momento del día
en la biblioteca tú puedes elegir de
nuestro catálogo de actividades las
actividades son las mismas la diferencia
estriba en cómo se presentan quieres
elegir las actividades que va a realizar
tu hijo o te gusta la idea de dejar que
siga la ruta de aprendizaje
personalizada tú tienes la decisión
en la parte técnica queremos señalar un
par de cosas si por alguna razón no
tienen conexión a internet puedes buscar
en la biblioteca el icono de equipaje
offline selecciónalo encontraras
actividades disponibles sin conexión
incluyendo create todo el avance de tu
hijo se guardará y se actualizará cuando
vuelvas a conectarte te recomendamos que
si puedes acompañar a tu hijo cuando use
la aplicación si no puedes o si ya tiene
la edad suficiente para hacerlo solo o
con la compañía de uno de sus hermanos
no te preocupes podrás ver su avance en
la biblioteca con marcas de color verde
amarillas o rojas que indican si ya
tiene dominio si está en progreso o aún
debe trabajar en eso si tienes más de un
hijo crea cuentas diferentes para ellos
para que pueda seguir su progreso por
separado
por el lado del contenido los padres nos
han señalado que les encanta usar los
libros que tenemos para leerles a sus
hijos hay libros de todos los temas
desde animales hasta sobre cómo lidiar
con la frustración puedes encontrarlos
en la sección books con la modalidad de
read to me con la cual podrás leerle a
tu hijo o read by myself en la que leerá
solo también nos han mencionado que
disfrutan los hábitos saludables que se
enseñan hay actividades para saludar
para hacer amigos incluso para vestirse
por la mañana algunos de estos hábitos
son especialmente importantes cuando
estamos confinados te invitamos a que
los busques en las secciones de jardín
de niños y preescolar en la pestaña de
logic
finalmente en la pestaña create tu hijo
puede hacer algo creativo como dibujar
hacer una carta para un amigo que puedes
capturar y enviar khan academy kids no
sólo se enfoca en las materias centrales
como lectura en matemáticas para niños
de 2 a 7 años también se asegura de que
los niños sean creativos que interactúen
contigo que se muevan se levanten y
salten y que hagan sonidos de animales
que realmente se desarrollen de manera
integral
si tienes dudas sobre cómo comenzar por
favor escríbenos a can kids
khan academy punto org te invitamos
también a seguirnos en nuestras redes
sociales instagram
facebook twitter y youtube para
encontrar actividades diarias cosas como
círculos time y qué hacer con tus hijos
en khan academy kits para más recursos
útiles sobre cómo apoyar a tu hijo para
que aprenda desde casa con khan academy
kids visita sigamos aprendiendo punto
khan academy punto org o sigamos
aprendiendo punto khan academy punto org
diagonal s si estás en los eeuu
y con eso terminamos gracias por darte
el tiempo de ver este tutorial